Donald Trump is going to be a
commandeering all of television or at
least all of it that has decided to go
along with this very obvious publicity
stunt that he's doing with the goal of
fear-mongering
about the non-existent immigration
crisis that Trump has fabricated in
order to justify taking money
potentially through the use of national
emergency declaration for his us-mexico
border wall over which he has already
shut down the government and most media
outlets are effectively complicit in
this and I'll talk about that at how
that works in a second from the
beginning of Trump's campaign he
fearmonger around immigration you'll
remember Mexico sending rapists and
criminals who bring drugs and crime we
will shut down Muslim immigration until
we can figure out what the hell is going
on we want people from Norway not from
[ __ ] whole countries like Haiti you can
say that now because it's quoting the
president we will build a wall and
Mexico will pay for it and then it
became clear that Mexico was never going
to pay so Trump instead demanded money
from you the taxpayer he couldn't get it
so he shut down the government which has
now gone on for more than two weeks and
now Donald Trump announced in a tweet
yesterday that he will address the
nation tonight on television saying
quote I am pleased to inform you isn't
he really that I will address the nation
capital a on address why we will never
know on the humanitarian and national
security crisis on our southern border
Tuesday night at 9:00 p.m. Eastern this
is propaganda this is a propaganda
speech the presidential Oval Office
evening address is or should be reserved
for actual crises or announcements of
consequence so I disagreed with going to
war with Iraq but I didn't disagree with
the use of the Oval Office nighttime
address for George W Bush to communicate
that on his orders bombings had started
in Iraq and a lead-up to our occupation
there when President Obama announced
that Osama bin Laden had been killed
although it wasn't at the Oval Office it
was an evening presidential address a
short one from the White House so what
Donald Trump is doing is he is holding
high
the imagery of the big presidential
announcement on national television to
lie and to tell us that this
non-existent immigration crisis is a
crisis when it's not and that gets us to
the networks and the TV channels who are
complicit by covering it if they don't
live fact-check which I hope that they
will because he's going to lie is ass
off and this is where I'm thinking of
doing a live stream tonight during which
I will live fact-check
Donald Trump's predicted to be 8 minutes
8 minutes statement to the American
people the reality is of course that
border crossing attempts are at historic
lows and have been declining since
before Donald Trump came into office so
the idea that border crossings are down
merely because people are scared of
Trump that's not true we have a net
outflow of undocumented immigrants to
Mexico rather than a coming in from
Mexico undocumented immigrants commit
crimes at lower rates than american-born
citizens they pay into social welfare
programs that they're never going to get
benefits out of the agriculture and
restaurant industries just to name two
would be crippled without undocumented
immigrants and of course without
documented immigrants there is no crisis
but ABC and CBS and NBC and Fox Network
and Fox News and CNN and MSNBC they are
all going to be carrying the speech so
Donald Trump is successfully
commandeering television for a pet
project waste of money that he has
concocted I'll remind you because it's
not just about evaluating how networks
will cover tonight's address but it's
also about the hypocrisy that is there
in their decision to air it at all when
President Obama wanted to address the
nation about executive actions on
immigration many major networks said
we're not going to air it because it's
quote overtly political a fake border
crisis possibly culminating in Trump
declaring a national emergency in order
to get money for his wall is the most
political way I can imagine of dealing
with the issue and we will see Pat how
these channels
deal with it I am I would rather them
not air it at all and later tell us what
was said and the truth or falsity of it
if they're going to do it they should
live fact-check I don't know if they
will for a few hours yesterday there was
a question over whether the networks
would air the speech and I was really
hoping that they would decide not to
because it's so overtly political and
because there's no real crisis at the
border but CBS decided to air it and the
other networks followed suit I hope that
at least like CNN does that live side by
side fact check thing they did a similar
thing with Sarah Huckabee Sanders at a
press conference at least do that or
give Pelosi Schumer and the Democrats
equal time to give their side of things
yeah and we'll talk about that at the
equal time idea on today's bonus show
and I'll mention right before tweeting
about the address which we were told
again will last eight minutes Trump
tweeted that the news media are crazed
lunatics and the enemy of the people and
now that same news media is doing
Trump's bidding so I may do a YouTube
livestream and I will alive fact check
if so my hope is that the address in the
history books will be seen as historians
as a turning point and a major political
mistake we'll see about that one of the
day's sponsors is privacy comm slash
Pakman which is a free service that I
myself use really useful in many
different ways takes just a few seconds
to link your debit card to privacy calm
then you can create virtual credit cards
that are linked directly to your bank
account and you use those virtual credit
card numbers to buy things online which
protects your actual debit card so that
it's not spread all over the internet
and one of the best things about it is
how their mobile app and browser
extensions for Chrome and Firefox make
it really easy to use let's say for
example that I'm signing up for a David
Pakman show membership in the credit
card number field I already see the
privacy comm icon I just click it choose
which of my virtual credit cards I want
to use and the credit card number
expiration date and security code are
automatically entered I can put in any
zip code I want and I'm done and if you
try to use my credit card number that
you just saw on the screen it doesn't
matter because I've already deleted that
virtual card and that's the beauty of
privacy comm there are a ton of
advantages to using a free service like
this for example you can sign up for as
many free trials as you want then just
delete the virtual credit card you used
and never worry about getting charged
for it it protects you from getting
hacked it protects you when companies
are hacked which happens all the time it
is all completely free all you have to
do is click the link under this video to
get started and for a limited time
they're giving everyone in our audience
$5 towards your first purchase when you
sign up using that link